[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission sera consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti à pour le
sommaire football ce dimanche à domicile
lui encore remporté le derby contre mort
pas en dire de district le score 3 buts
à 1 tous les détails sur ce match
spectaculaire sont à venir dans cette
édition et cauterets la 11e édition
s'est déroulée ce samedi au départ de
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
plus de 2500 concurrents se sont
inscrits pour le 80 km malgré des
conditions climatiques difficiles coup
de projecteur dans ce magazine football
le trophée gol de letra sera organisée
ce samedi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le tournoi
caritatif a été créée par rail l'ancien
footballeur du psg qui sera présent pour
l'événement avec d'autres joueurs
professionnels
coup de projecteur à présent sur les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
football en première division de
district guyancourt a réussi un petit
exploit en sent pas en s'imposant sur
son terrain contre le deuxième du
classement à maurepas le score 3 buts à
1 dans un match spectaculaire à
rebondissements le résumé des images
sont signés à nicolas landry un nouveau
derby sulfureux entre maurepas et
guyancourt après s'être quittés sur un
match nul 2 buts partout en novembre
dernier et deux équipes se retrouver sur
la pelouse des rouges de guyancourt
après une première période équilibrée
l'aiguillon courtois marque juste avant
la mi temps
donc c'est un but qui nous qui nous mais
bien parce qu'on finit bien la mi-temps
donc du coup on a su à ce moment là
justement appuyer où ça faisait mal et
marquer au bon moment vraiment très bon
mois au retour des vestiaires
l'aiguillon courtois font le break suite
cette interception avant que maurepas ne
réduise l'écart sur penalty quelques
minutes plus tard c'est vrai qu'on était
un fossé là dessus parce que on savait
qu'à deux ans allait être compliqué et
qu'ils allaient s'accrocher jusqu'à la
fin donc malgré quelques situations
chaudes en défense et finalement
guillaucourt qui aura le dernier mot
les rouges réussissent à convertir un
contre avec un peu de réussite
score final 3 buts à 1 on a su faire le
dos rond et bien résisté puis on savait
qu'en deuxième partie de saison on a 2
ème partie de la mi temps par dont on à
avoir les armes ou surtout offensivement
et physiquement pour aller chercher
cette victoire
quand on est dans le camp adverse sans
moyens des espaces qui se créent
d'arrière dans notre dos et voilà on a
pris les trois buts comme ça aujourd'hui
donc pas de regrets parce que
voilà on a joué on a eu un bon
comportement après voilà c'est des
erreurs techniques qui nous coûte
sûrement le match aujourd'hui
les deux équipes pourraient se retrouver
au mois de juin pour la finale de la
coupe des yvelines en attendant maurepas
deuxième le compte plus que trois points
d'avancé sur son adversaire du jour
dans les autres rencontres de cette
première division de district le fc
mantois s'est imposé 1-0 contre epône le
son côté montigny le bretonneux avant
dernier du championnat a réussi à
arracher le match nul sur le terrain
d'hardricourt 1 but partout
un résultat qui permet au club de
revenir à deux points de la place de non
relégable
à noter également la défaite des joueurs
des clayes-sous-bois l'extérieur 3-2 sur
le terrain de l' us le pecq
enfin les mureaux se sont imposés sur le
terrain de gargenville sur le score de 2
buts à 0 toujours en football mais cette
fois ci dans le championnat de r4 trappe
n'y arrive toujours pas ce dimanche les
hommes d'arnaud et bizi se sont inclinés
1 but à 0 sur le terrain de mots une
équipe classée dans le top 4 du
championnat
au classement cette défaite mais les
trappistes sous pression ils flirtent
toujours avec la zone de relégation la
11e place sur 14 équipes avec seulement
15 points engrangés depuis le début du
championnat
il y avait également du rugby ce
week-end ont joué dans le championnat de
fédérale 2 plaisir 10e a signé une très
belle victoire 26 23 à domicile contre
marcq en baroeul ce dimanche l'équipe
qui les précèdent au classement ce
résultat permet aux plaisirs roi de
prendre le large sur la zone de
relégation avec neuf points d'avancé sur
le premier relégable
arras le maintien est presque
mathématiquement assurée à cinq journées
de la fin du championnat
rugby toujours le maintien lui n'est
toujours pas assurée pour le sky rugby
en honneur les saint quentinois se sont
inclinés ce dimanche lors de la 16e
journée du championnat contre l'entente
maisons laffitte saint germain les
poissy deuxième du championnat le score
26 à 22 e au classement le sky reste
avant-dernier à deux points du premier
non relégable le assez paris15 prochain
match dimanche prochain sur le terrain
du dernier à brétigny c'est l'une des
courses les plus compliqués en
ile-de-france l'eco trail de paris
s'était lancé ce samedi depuis l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
au programme 1 80 km sur les sentiers
verts en passant par bus en cours but
kevin esi villacoublay
avant de terminer sur le premier étage
de la tour eiffel tout cela dans des
conditions climatiques compliquées
nicolas landry pour les images un record
de participants pour cette et cauterets
ils étaient plus de 2500 courageux à
s'être inscrits au départ du 80 km
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines
objectif rejoindre le premier étage de
la tour eiffel c'est sympa c'est une
bonne ambiance
j'irais pas jusqu'a dire qu'on est entre
locaux mais c'est le plus collectif des
sports individuels que je connais ont
fait un bout de route avec quelqu'un on
le lâche en cours avec quelqu'un d'autre
c'est sympa comme tous les participants
qui ont dû faire face à des températures
glaciales proche des 0 degré pour
combattre ces conditions climatiques
chaque trailer assez technique à au
mental avec un bon petit coup de vent et
puis bien se réchauffer entre entre
coureurs entre coureurs que froid le
froid et du coup l'alimentation aussi
s'alimenter et s'hydrater régulièrement
pour ne pas avoir qu'une mousse sur la
fin autre difficulté un terrain très
gras télé premiers mètres sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
en effet des zones qui sont assez
inondées justement avec beaucoup de
flaques d'eau et là ça va être un peu
compliqué sur certains passages des
conditions compliquées qui n'ont pas
refroidi le vainqueur de l'épreuve
emmanuel meyssat tu ce sportif de
l'extrême a bouclé les 80 km en 6 heures
et 59 secondes
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition de la course à pied
également à voisins le bretonneux c'est
une tradition dans la vie la 38e édition
de la course du printemps était
programmé ce dimanche matin au départ du
centre sportif les pyramides
au programme des courses nature de 3 km
pour les collégiens la grande ville
chinoise pour les plus de 16 ans mais la
course phare de cette journée était un
trail de 15 km sur le site des granges
de port royal
on écoute les réactions des 710 coureur
inscrit juste avant le départ au micro
de nicolas landry j'aime bien tout ce
qui est compétition et puis tout surtout
le dimanche ça c'est convivial
j'ai vu que j'habite en plus la commune
c'est l'idéal comme moscou régulièrement
j'aime bien ça c'est vraiment
agréable et puis là je connaissais pas
besoin bretonneux voilà une constance
nature c'est toujours plus sympa que sur
route 15 km on verra c'est ça risque
d'être sympa way jodar on à poil nous
sommes prêtes on ouvre une page
taekwondo l'école de taekwondo de
trappes a brillé lors des derniers
championnats de france de montpellier au
début du mois remportant quatre
médailles
nesrine et bar est notamment devenue
championne junior féminine dans la
catégorie moins de 55 kg et égalise
tarawih est devenu à vice champion de
france junior masculin en moins de 63 kg
nous avons la chance de recevoir ces
deux sportifs ainsi que leur président
michel burel sur ce plateau bons soirs
comme ça alors ce sont des résultats qui
étaient attendus président alors attendu
on n'a jamais de résultats vraiment
attendu dans ces catégories d'âge on est
content du résultat serait qu'on
espérait des podiums après que nisrine
monte sur la plus haute marche et
égalise sur la deuxième marche était
vraiment de bons résultats pour nous
c'est une confirmation du travail aussi
en amont de ces jeunes et de travail
aussi les éducateurs près tous ces
jeunes donc on est vraiment contents des
résultats il ya également les deux
troisièmes places en cadet de deux
jeunes de la petite soeur de yanis il y
voilà qui a fini donc deuxièmes et de
mohamed mendy et qualifie également fini
deuxièmes
donc on était vraiment contenu que
content de ces résultats
donc il y avait dix sportifs du club qui
se sont déplacés sur ces championnats de
france 4 ont été médaillés
c'est un bon bilan selon vous où vous
auriez pu faire mieux encore mieux on
espère toujours faire mieux ce qu'on
nourrit beaucoup d'espoirs avec ces
jeunes surtout cannavo qui ont beaucoup
de potentiel
après ça reste quand même un très bon
résultat les championnats de france
juniors c'est toujours incertain on a vu
beaucoup de
de champion en titre qui était attendu
non pas ne sont pas montés sur la
première marche notamment grâce à yanis
cas priver le champion en titre de 2 200
titres
donc on était on aurait été content pour
sas et c'était vraiment très bien
donc non pour revenir à l'ensemble des
jeunes en c'est un bon résultat
quatre médailles sur dix engagés c'est
un très bon résultat est ici tu as donc
terminé à la deuxième place tu pouvais
faire mieux oui c'est vrai ben déjà j'ai
une demi finale assez compliqué et c'est
ce qui a un peu joué parce que j'ai
enchaîné les combats et de ce fait j'ai
été moins concentrés dans la finale mais
j'aurais pu faire mieux il ya des
regrets ou pas non parce que c'est déjà
un beau bilan c'est une bonne expérience
et après bah du coup je vais continuer à
travailler pour pouvoir monter sur la
première marche toi de ton côté
les screen tu as terminé championne on
peut dire c'est une habitude pour toi un
qui al habitude de terminer saute dans
les premières places des compétitions au
niveau national pas vraiment parce qu'on
n'est pas à l'abri d'une défaite
donc quoi qu'il arrive il rien n'est
fait perdre
et qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
dans ce tournoi pour toi j'étais
déterminé je voulais gagner le titre
come back comme tout le monde france etc
les entraînements au sikkim
mesrine c'est une surprise ou pas
qu'elle remporte ce titre de championne
pas vraiment elle a déjà été championne
de france ya deux ans en cadets elle
avait confirmé avec une troisième
médaille européenne
donc ça c'était vraiment un bon résultat
et pour cause c'était une belle surprise
on l'attendait pas à ce niveau il ya
déjà il ya deux ans donc elle confirme à
la une année un peu plus difficile à une
dernière mais comme elle l'a dit le
travail plaît paix et surtout la
détermination on a deux jeunes ici qui
sont vraiment de gros travailleur c'est
ce qui les disent nos jeunes si 15 ans
et 16 ans et ça tout à fait 15 16 ans
qui sont encore tout jeune et qui ont
vraiment encore un bel avenir devant eux
s'ils continuent à travailler ils ont
encore d'une belle marge de progression
donc au dessus des autres ils sont au
dessus des autres des 142 potentiel ils
sont pas forcément au dessus des autres
mais en terme de travail et ce que
disent et nisrine en terme de mental je
pense que oui sont légèrement au dessus
mais c'est toujours ce qui fait la
différence entre un bon sportif et un
champion c'est ce que pour toi qu'est ce
qui fait la différence enter dans tes
combats si souvent de taille je mesure 1
m 72 chili une des plus grandes de ma
catégorie sa fin c'est ta force pas
vraiment j'ai aussi la souplesse
soucasse également et toi de ton côté
du coup il ya ni ce mois ci à la taille
qui joue un peu mais après c'est aussi
est vraiment le mental pour pouvoir
accrocher jusqu'au bout et gagner
parfois dans les derniers moments
il ya une politique qui est mise en
place à trappes pour les aider à grandir
alors on a une politique on a déjà
beaucoup de beaucoup de jeunes depuis
quelques années avec les éducateurs de
nice et avec le papa de yanis jawad
chouba et la mairie qui nous soutient
aussi on pousse vraiment beaucoup de
jeunes on a beaucoup de monde il n'y a
pas que du sport de haut niveau on a une
masse de jeunes importante on va arriver
à quasiment 300 licenciés cette année
donc ça fait beaucoup de personnes à
gérer et on a c'est vrai un pôle
compétition qu'on appuie avec des
échanges aussi avec d'autres clubs ont
fait beaucoup de déplacements pour les
jeunes pour qu'ils puissent être
confronté avec aux autres sportifs des
autres des autres clubs donc
régulièrement des confrontations à
l'extérieur pour justement voir un peu
ce qui le niveau et pousser nos jeunes à
travailler ils se remettre en question
en permanence pour pouvoir avancer
il ya les infrastructures pour leur
permettre de grandir
oui on a de belles infrastructures sur
la ville de trappes on aimerait toujours
toujours plus puisque le club grandit
mais c'est vrai qu'on a des belles
infrastructures et jusqu'à présent la
mairie ne fit bien dans notre
développement
vous êtes bien trappe ou de votre côté
nesrine même chose vous songez pas
changé club
rassurez-nous bas j'ai déjà changé de
club avant je n'étais pas à trappes
mais en voyant l'investissement qu'il y
avait de tout le personnel pour les
compétiteurs les déplacements et les la
qualité des entraînements je suis venu à
trappes et ça m'a permis de beaucoup
progresser
quelle est la prochaine échéance pour
ces deux sportifs alors de grosses
échéances en grosses échéances et à la
fin de la semaine les championnats de
france espoirs des moins de 21 ans donc
là où vont être confrontés également
avec des athlètes qui sont déjà à
seniors donc ont plus de 18 ans donc
c'est un c'est un cap aussi parce que
physiquement
un jeune qui a 18 21 ans déjà un peu
plus mature donc ça va être une belle
confrontation pour eux une belle épreuve
mais tout est possible
objectif médaille objectif une médaille
ce serait vraiment un bon résultat ça va
être ça va être un peu plus difficile
déjà que les championnats de france
juniors merci à tous les trois le passé
sur ce plateau est de remporter de
nouvelles compétitions dans les
prochains jours merci et on continuera à
vous suivre sur tv 78 un mot d'aviron à
présent ce dimanche les régates de
versailles était organisée sur le grand
canal du château qu'on peut le voir sur
ces photos prises par le cercle nautique
de versailles mille deux cents
compétiteurs venus d'une quarantaine de
clubs de toute la france ont participé à
cet événement programmé tous les deux
ans sur le site historique conçu par
louis xiv au niveau du public
l'événement qui réunit à chaque édition
plusieurs milliers le spectateur n'a pas
fait le plein avec des conditions
climatiques difficiles
si vous voulez découvrir l'ensemble des
résultats les tableaux sont à retrouver
sur le site internet du cercle nautique
de versailles
même si les régates de versailles n'ont
pas attiré une foule immense sur un
invité de marque s'est glissé parmi les
spectateurs comme on peut le voir sur
cette photo emmanuel macron est venu
encourager en fin d'après-midi les 1200
sportif sur les bords du canal
le président de la république est venu
en voisin ils séjournaient dans la
résidence d'état de la lanterne situé à
quelques pas du bassin du cyclisme
à présent les championnats du monde sur
piste paralympiques début de cette
semaine au brésil
al'approche de cette échéance les
pistards français sont venus à
s'entraîner sur le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
parmi eux on retrouve rafael beaugier
qui partira en tandem avec ken dujarrier
du club de vélizy 78 en montage de et
xavier jaglin depuis plusieurs jours ce
tandem enchaîne les tours de piste sur
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
raphaël bougies athlètes touchées par un
handicap visuel eliane dujarrier du club
de vélizy 78 doivent peaufiner les
derniers détails avant de s'envoler pour
les championnats du monde handisport
programmée au brésil les 22 et 23 mars
pour l'instant ça fonctionne plutôt pas
mal après baffour encore qu'on apprenne
à se connaître c'est comme un bac comme
un couple est plus là bas ya le côté
sportif faut qu'on se règlent bas sur
les braquer et tout ce qui va avec quoi
pédaler à deux dans le même sens une
nouvelle expérience pour hygiène
dujarrier ce sportif et binoy de 41 ans
vice champion du monde masters s'est
associé à ce projet avec l'équipe de
france depuis le mois de janvier
ces prêts valorisant pour moi de me dire
que ben voila je peux être accompagné
quelqu'un et aider quelqu'un à réaliser
ses objectifs et a réalisé des choses
qui leur auraient pu faire si l'ipad
avec moi comme je vais à l'entraînement
aux entraînements que je peux faire tout
seul je les fais plus de la même manière
c'est vrai que je m'entraîne pour lui je
m'entraîne plus pour moi et ça c'est
autre chose
après une première expérience en
championnat de france handisport en
janvier couronné par une qualification
mondiaux les deux athlètes espère
désormais passer un cap au niveau des
résultats et s'aligneront sur la vitesse
et le kilomètre on espère pouvoir entrer
dans les dix ce qui nous permettrait de
marquer des points
au niveau au niveau mondial et ensuite
il faudrait qu'on passe dans les huit
premiers pour pouvoir accéder au tournoi
final
et là ce serait la cerise sur le gâteau
il premières échéances internationales
avant de viser le graal prône athlètes
handisport les jeux paralympiques de
tokyo en 2020 on passe maintenant notre
rubrique agenda
[Musique]
on commence à tajan départ de la course
à pied la direction des sports de la
ville de trappes organise le 15 avril
prochain son premier semi marathon dans
la ville avec au programme 80 % de
parcours en pleine nature pour nous
parler de ce rendez-vous nous recevons
sur ce plateau ali arhab et adjoint au
maire de trappes délégué à la jeunesse
et aux sports bonsoir bonsoir
alors pourquoi avoir voulu créer ce semi
marathon à parce qu'on a voulu enrichir
le calendrier sportif de la ville
on a de nombreux clubs qui l'animent
tout au long de l'année mais il nous
manquait une course sur la ville de
trappes qui permettent de rassembler les
différentes générations
les petits qui corrompt sur des courses
d'un kilomètre 5 et 3 km mais également
les sportifs aguerris qui pourront
couvrir celui marathon de 21,1 km le
projet était dans les cartons depuis de
nombreuses années mais que tu as une
volonté de la part des sportifs de
trappes
j'ai été beaucoup sollicité depuis mon
élection à la mairie et ma désignation
sur la fonction d'adjoint au maire aux
sports par des trappistes souvent des
sportifs aguerris qui me demandaient si
on pouvait organiser sur la commune une
course de ce type
moi j'ai souhaité le faire mais j'ai
souhaité immédiatement associé le grand
public ne pas faire uniquement une
course de sportifs professionnels ou
habitués au semi marathon mais en faire
un moment festif un vrai événement
sportif sur la ville qui réunira les
familles je le disais 80% du programme
se fera en pleine nature c'est un peu la
mode on peut le dire il ya de nombreux
traits qui sont organisées dans la
région
vous avez écouté les avis des runner sur
ce tracé
bien sûr on a travaillé d'abord le
projet avec l'entente athlétique de
saint quentin en yvelines
le grand club d'athlétisme de
de 50 ans et on a décidé de faire à la
fois découvrir la ville de trappes dans
sa diversité notamment les nouveaux
quartiers qui ont été construits
récemment mais également profité de ce
parcours exceptionnel sur la base de
loisirs qui permet sur 20% donc du
parcours d'être en zone urbaine et sur
80 % en zone naturelle on a une île de
loisirs il faut évidemment profiter
pourquoi avoir choisi la base de l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
ce site accueille de nombreuses
compétitions c'est le choix c'est
forcément porté vers l'île des loisirs
parce qu'à ses légions l'eco-trail par
exemple a été organisée le week-end
dernier sur ce site
parce que c'est naturellement l'île de
loisirs allait quand même si tu est
quasi intégralement sur la commune de
trappes donc ne pas en profiter quand on
réunit les trappistes pour courir ce
serait quand même dommage donc on a
choisi évidemment de profiter à plein de
ce site et vous pensez que ce semi
marathon ne pas attirer des sportifs
confirmés
evidon parliez des familles mais
également des sportifs confirmés
pourrait venir j'ai su compléter six
mentions bien sûr l'intérêt c'est que
les publics ne s'excluent pas au
contraire les sportifs confirmés il ya
beaucoup de coureurs attrapa on les voit
déambuler les week-ends notamment quand
il fait beau et courir sur l'île de
loisirs mais pas que également dans la
rue ou dans les dans les bois et tous
ces sportifs évidemment seront présents
au rendez vous vous savez je croise des
gens en ville là qui me parle du semi
marathon c'est des directeurs d'école
c'est des sportifs plus ou moins engagés
dans la course et on les retrouvera au
rendez-vous semi marathon et puis il ya
aussi des sportifs qui viendront bientôt
de la trappe de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de l'ensemble
du sud yvelines
il faudra être un bon coureur pour
participer à ce semi marathon pour
courir un semi-marathon il vaut mieux
avoir un peu d'entraînement c'est
certain mais moi qui ne suis pas un
grand coureur par exemple je m'entraîne
pour faire la course de 10 km et pour
ceux qui sont peut-être un peu plus
modestes ils pourront courir sur de plus
petites distances il ya 10 km 5 km et 10
km surtout pour les enfants à 1,5 et 3
km honnêtement les collégiens vous
pourquoi pas les lycéens mais il ya des
catégories d'âge évidemment puisque tout
cela est encadrée par des normes et des
cadres relativement stricte vous espère
attirer comme une personne c'est une
première édition à la vocation se
répéter chaque année donc nous on espère
attirer à peu près 300 personnes au delà
ce sera un grand succès populaire
et comment tirer les personnes vers ce
type de compétition il ya énormément de
concurrence dans la région on parlait
tout à l'heure il
la course de printemps par exemple de
voisins-le-bretonneux comment on fait
pour attirer se démarquer une autre
course
on a choisi une date en fonction aussi
du calendrier des semi marathons du
département l'objectif n'est pas de
saturer le calendrier donc on a choisi
un moment où on pense que le public
répondra au rendez vous on communique
évidemment dans les revues spécialisées
et on communique en direction du grand
public dont tous les trappistes reçoit
l'information dans leur boîte aux
lettres dans les gymnases dans les
équipements publics et on invite les
familles à participer surtout un petit
mot par exemple pour vous dire que vous
receviez juste avant l'école taekwondo
de trappes qui est alors soit d'un qui a
fait d'excellents résultats sportifs le
week-end dernier et bien l'école
taekwondo trappe proposera par exemple
une démonstration initiation au
taekwondo sur le site sur le gymnase qui
accueillera l'arrivée de la course
donc l'idée c'est d'inclure tous les
clubs locaux sur la ville où on applique
les sportifs aguerris
les sportifs du dimanche comme moi les
amateurs les enfants les familles les
papas les mamans évidemment et des
associations proposeront des stands et
on aura des associations sportives qui
feront qui montreront toutes leurs
compétences
est-ce qu'on peut encore s'inscrire sur
cet événement bien sûr on peut
s'inscrire c'est comment on fait pour
s'inscrire suffit d'aller sur le site
internet de la ville de trappes vous
aurez accès à toutes les informations et
aux inscriptions en ligne
on peut s'inscrire également directement
en mairie trappe au service des sports
et on pourra surtout s'inscrire le jour
j
si certains se décident au dernier
moment ceux qui notamment regarde la
météo pourront venir le dimanche matin
s'inscrire sur site
c'est donc un semi marathon est ce que
dans les années qui viennent il pourrait
y avoir un marathon ici à trappes
pourquoi pas installons déjà le semi
marathon dans le paysage sportif et en
fonction du succès et de la demande
pourquoi pas un jour aller jusqu'au
marathon c'est possible
rien n'est impossible merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau nous ferons
un reportage il vous plaît sur cet
événement dans un prochain à 7,8 sport
je vous rappelle le semi marathon le
trap sont organisées le 15 avril
prochain
juste à côté de l'île des loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines va
accueillir à partir de 17h le trophée
gol de letra ce sera ce samedi le
concept des matches caritatifs sur
militaires seront organisées dans l'air
central de la structure et permettront
de voir en action des anciennes gloires
du pg comme raï le créateur de
l'association nous avons pu rencontrer
le responsable communication de
l'événement au regard des nous sommes au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le futur
théâtre du trophée gol de letra qui sera
organisée
ce samedi dans cette enceinte est à mes
côtés le responsable communication
franck joubert font que joubert quel est
le concept de l'événement
alors chaque année on organise un
tournoi interentreprises qui se termine
par des matches de gala ouvert au public
il y aura des stars du psg enfin des
anciennes stars du psg dans sa star
brésilienne des internationaux et il y
aura de la batucada de la capoiera les
ultras du psg viendront en nombre pour
mettre l'ambiance
on attend près de 3000 personnes
tous les fonds générés par cet événement
sont reversés à l'association gol de
letra qui aide les enfants en situation
de précarité au brésil à se scolariser
avec double action sociale et scolaire
l'action est principalement sur sao
paulo et sur rio de janeiro voilà donc
ça a été écrit quand ce que ça fait là
c'est la quinzième édition du tournoi
l'association a 20 ans elle est reconnue
par l'unesco c'est nous on est là la
version française de l'association qui
apportons le souffle de la station en
france et qui est dont énormément la
fondation brésilienne à récolter des
fonds pour les aider dans les pousser
dans leurs actions
et pourquoi le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parce que je
suis de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et je
sais que le vélodrome est un lieu idéal
pour propulser l'événement sur une un
public qui a kara parfaitement
l'événement je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
fans de football dans le coin donc je
sais très bien qu'il ya possibilité de
faire un très très bel événement ici on
peut accueillir jusqu'à 5000 personnes
dans cette structure est ce que vous
pensez pouvoir avoir autant de monde ce
samedi
vu la communication qui a démarré la
manière dont on est reçu je pense qu'on
sera potentiellement plein donc on
conseille aux personnes de prendre via
la billetterie en ligne
ces gosses delétraz point fr le billet
c'est 5 euros l'entrée mais c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 12 ans vous
pouvez acheter en ligne qui vous
permettra de ne pas faire la queue le
jour j car l'événement dure deux heures
ils commencent à 17h et tendre à 19
heures c'est très très conseillé de
réserver à l'avancé vos billets donc il
ya se déplace et reste des places
aujourd'hui au niveau des stars du coup
vous disais des anciens du psg notamment
alors il y aura rail qui nous fera
l'honneur d'être ici malgré le fait
qu'il ait repris là
la responsabilité du club de sao paulo
il un match le dimanche donc il prendra
l'avion le samedi soir après l'événement
il y aura luis fernandez sera
amara simba les anciens du psg au sein
du psg des anciens brésiliens et des
amis même y aura fournis et il y aura
des champion olympique de cyclisme ça se
prête à au lieu on a un beau parterre de
vip enfin ça va être une très très belle
ambiance avec des très belles personnes
et sur le terrain ça va se passer
comment il y aura plusieurs matchs
pendant la soirée
il y aura trois matches de gala des
spectacles de cap aura fait par
l'association d'elancourt il y aura de
la batucada il y aura des surprises et à
quel moment on va se dire que
l'événement aurait réussi ce sera une
première quand même alors c'est la
première sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
nous notre objectif c'est de
rassembler un maximum de personnes
idéalement aussi de faire un bel
événement familial
donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait des places
gratuites pour les moins de 12 ans pour
qu'il ya un maximum d'enfants et de ce
que ça va dans la thématique de l'action
de la fondation gol de letra et est-ce
qu'il y aura d'autres événements de ce
type à ce que l'objectif c'est de
pérenniser l'événement ici au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout à fait
donc là c'est la première fois qu'on
fait au vélodrome
si ça se passe bien s'il ya du monde qui
répondent à l'appel
très clairement on reproduire à
l'événement l'année prochaine et c'est
clairement mon objectif personnel
donc c'est vrai carton c'est dans les
cartons hérail pareil il et il est ok
pour rester ici à saint quentin et pour
l'instant on est tous très positif à
cette idée merci beaucoup
l'événement godet les tracés ce samedi
au vélodrome nationale 2 à saint quentin
en yvelines et on termine ce magazine
par un rendez-vous boxe ce week-end vers
hyérois ahmed el moussaoui va affronter
le hongrois gabor gorbicz au palais des
sports de marseille dans la catégorie
des poids welters l'illinois partir avec
un léger avantage il n'a connu que trois
défaites et un nul en trente et une
confrontation chez les professionnels de
son côté le boxeur de hongrie surnommé
l'écureuil a remporté 24 matchs pour 9
défaites
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]